nous sommes aujourd'hui dans le loiret
et plus exactement à orléans alors vous
connaissez certainement sa cathédrale et
ses deux tours de plus de 80 mètres de
haut
mais aujourd'hui c'est sous un autre
édifice que nous allons aller sous
l'église saint-aignan dédié à son évêque
du même nom elle date du vème siècle une
balade à travers les entrailles de la
ville où nous tenteront de décrypter le
mystère de la crypte un reportage
réalisé avec charlie krief lawrence
bories et laurent vos rides c'est par
ici la visite de la crypte saint-aignan
tout à fait c'est par ici et suivez moi
s'il est un homme qui connaît bien les
lieux ses frères guillaume entraînons
entraînements le gardien des clés
une fois la porte passée la crypte
souterraine s'ouvre devant vous alors
nous sommes ou là exactement
nous sommes ici en plein coeur de la
crypte saint-aignan crypte creusé à
partir du 10e siècle suite à l' incendie
d'orléans qui a tout détruit en 989
après jésus-christ
elle permettait avant tout d'entreposer
mais surtout de protéger les reliques de
saint-aignan l'évêque enterré j puisque
est devenu le saint patron protecteur de
la ville en 453 après jésus-christ et
qu'est ce qu'on y trouve de particuliers
dans cette crypte eh bien on y trouve
surtout sa décoration d'origine comme
ici avec cette magnifique sculpture sur
ce chapiteau sculptures qui a été
conservée depuis le xème siècle et qui
conserve encore aujourd'hui ses couleurs
du 10ème siècle durant plus de dix
siècles l'église saint-aignan et sa
crypte ont bien changé donc ça ressemble
beaucoup une fenêtre métier boucher
alors elle est bouché puisque au xième
siècle
effectivement c'est une fenêtre car le
niveau du sol dans une crypte romane est
beaucoup plus bas qu'il a été par la
suite au xvème siècle niveau de l'époque
gothique
nous sommes en plein dans l'art roman on
ne sait pas à construire des choses
aussi haute
telle qu'on la voit aujourd'hui cette
crypte c'est suite à la guerre de cent
ans et la reconstruction de l'église
et là je vous invite à me suivre nous
allons voir l'endroit le plus important
de cette crypte
[Musique]
nous arrivons ici en montant sur ces
trois marches à ce qu'on appelle le
martyrium lieu où sont entreposés les
reliques de saint-aignan mais même s'il
ya une porte
ici personne n'a le droit de pénétrer
par cette porte chaque pèlerin se place
là où je suis placé et ils ont le droit
de regarder les reliques par cette
petite ouverture qui est ici et ils
n'ont pas le droit de toucher et
reliques
ils peuvent juste les observer
je suis avec guillaume foussadier qui
est guide conférencier ici à orléans
alors on l'a vu lors de la visite avec
frère guillaume la crypte saint-aignan à
des secrets on a délivré certains mais
cache encore que certaines choses et oui
tout à fait puisque pendant la visite
vous n'avez vu qu'une partie de ce
qu'était cette crypte là il faut savoir
qu'elle a été en partie remblayer cet
ancien crypte pour justement soutenir
les travaux qui ont été faits pour
construire une église plus hautes au
xvème siècle est ainsi qu'ils ont
disparu quatre chapelles et toute une
partie du déambulatoire donc ce couloir
qui fait tout le tour ça on ne sait
absolument pas à quoi il ressemble ni
kendra secret il pourrait renfermer et à
orléans ce n'est pas le seul site
souterrain qu'on peut visiter en tout
cas et qui existent alors qu'ils
existent on peut en dénombrer encore 4
qu'on peut faire visiter malheureusement
on peut en faire que deux on peut faire
la crypte saint-avit qui était juste
sous l'église saint-avit alors qu'en
fait visiter au même titre que l'église
que la crypte à saint-aignan mais aussi
on va avoir la porte banier qui est en
fait un vestige de l'ancienne porte qui
servait de protection qui était incluse
dans nos remparts tout ça on va les
faire visiter tout à fait les sites on
peut malheureusement pas vite et c'est
sous la cathédrale ça exactement on va
avoir un site sous la cathédrale qui va
être une crypte donc une crypte tour va
avoir enterré à l'intérieur des
chevaliers qui fait partie de tout un
sol archéologiques
malheureusement qui n'est pas du tout
ouvert au public des questions de
préservation mais aussi on va avoir par
exemple aussi un ossuaire sous
église notre dame des miracles qui lui
non plus n'est pas accessible pour des
raisons de sécurité et la crypte
saint-aignan on peut la visiter toute
l'année à tout à fait tout à fait on va
avoir une programmation beaucoup plus
dense quand même pour la période
estivale où on va là proposé très
fréquemment mais toute l'année on va
quand même l'ouvrir aux visites et tout
ça encore une fois on va pouvoir le
retrouver sur notre site internet ou
directement en bureau à l'accueil de
notre office de tourisme merci quant à
nous nous nous retrouvons demain pour
une nouvelle visite du patrimoine
souterrain en région centre val de loire